[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum wow
special guests today Ryan I mean there's
always special guests I know but special
guests plural I know the creators of
Smallville the creators of Wednesday the
creators of the new Beetlejuice that's
going to come out
they're here Al Goff Miles Miller
it's always a joy to have them on they
come on The Talk fill podcast for some
insights yes Al's always is readily
available for me
um thank you for listening to the
podcast and supporting it without my
patrons patreon.com inside of you we
cannot do the show so if you want to
support the podcast and keep it going
and you're digging it please uh become a
patron and help support uh also the
inside of your online store that's cool
stuff uh Smallville lunch boxes and Lex
Luthor Funko pops and Flash Funko pops
and uh Lex Luthor statue and a bunch of
inside of you stuff tons of cool stuff
new tumblers so I go to inside of you
online store for that uh I will be in
Wales
yeah doing a con in Wales in early May
and then I'll be in Virginia Beach
Tidewater it's called the Tidewater con
or something Virginia Beach
um right after that
um so anyway come see me uh the handles
to listen or to follow on the podcast
and please write a review it truly helps
the show and the algorithms and all that
[__] it brings us up and it's great if
you write a review and follow some
handles what are they Ryan uh inside of
you pod on Twitter inside of your
podcast on Instagram and Facebook yes
that is it uh I I've been dealing with a
puppy right as you know it's um yeah I
thought of giving him back
uh he is shooting his crate three times
he only shits when I leave but then he
cannot [__] for 12 hours while I'm home
while I'm sleeping so I um
do I just accept that I can sleep at
least a little bit and just accept that
he's gonna [__] all over his crate I
have to probably fix that do you know
how many times I bathed him in the last
three days because he had [__] all over
him I won't get into it
but Charlie start behaving yourself
uh I hope you're enjoying the podcast
and uh let's just get inside of Al Goff
and Miles Miller it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience we were talking before when you
guys first came in
you guys were I just was joking around
like who's more high maintenance and it
was very much like twin brothers in a
way how they would respond to the answer
you're like well I guess I am no no you
know what you are well I don't know if I
guess I am I mean it was like who who's
more high maintenance and high
maintenance obviously not extreme but
who would be the more high maintenance I
I think it's definitely me I completely
agree no question there's no questions
it is though like for instance like
miles is actually very good about miles
what I I call it roughing it now in my
in my in my Advanced years I know what I
mean like you know I like things a
certain way like when even when we go on
location because we'll
you know we have places our apartments
are generally near each other right and
and but miles would be much happier like
when we were in Romania we stayed in
this very nice kind of soulless but very
nice
but it was attached to like you know it
had a gym attached to it and the Wi-Fi
was great and it was very clean is that
like I was fine there and I think Miles
was like pulling his heroin would have
rather lived in downtown Bucharest it's
definitely more an adventurer he's way
more a creature pattern
I have to say I'm with you yeah on that
so I'm not a great traveler I uh I tend
to uh I'm a bit of a Hermit I don't like
to be on a schedule for vacation like
we're gonna wake up at eight we're gonna
go do this we're gonna be out all day
we're gonna be you know absolutely
weirdly I'm that I'm then I'm fine when
we go on but again he doesn't do the
schedule I don't do the schedule see
what I like about the vacation is tell
me where we're going we can be literally
sometimes I'm like where are we going I
don't even tell me where I'm going just
what day Great Wall I'll show up get on
the plane you know and are you good with
that do you not complain when someone
else organizes things because I I hate
that no but by the way am I in my
younger you know I've been married 26
years now and my wife is an excellent
or you know traveler Ranger arranger and
snow and scheduler and those will be
like so but basically by the way that is
the thing now where it's like you know
what
I didn't I've yeah well I will say
though the one time that we were
together we were shooting the Hannah
Montana movie down in in Nashville and
we got to go to Memphis for the weekend
to be visali the judges in the barbecue
festival in Memphis that's a big deal we
knew nothing about barbecue but but
I wanted to go to Graceland and said oh
let's go to Graceland in the office and
he said okay sure and then he blew me
off and I ended up not going to
Graceland just like I always I just said
so you've never been no
I know right I could be in Memphis and
not go to Graceland I blame him
completely to that how come on man right
by the way I know I wish I went to
Graceland yeah so now I just drag him
whatever we do so we're in Romania
shooting Wednesday we went to like the I
forced him to go to the places he should
go to yeah did you like it were you
grateful for that you know what it is
and and I know this about myself I'll
[__] and moan but then when I'm there I
actually enjoy it and I know that about
myself like I'm I'm at like yeah and
sometimes I try to like skip the
bitching and moaning phase and get right
to like I'll be fine it'll be you know
that's good because I I but I'm yeah
there's nothing I hate more when I and
we'll get into your this is fun talk I
organize a lot of things yes Ryan's not
on Mike right now because we have you
guys but Ryan as I organize softball I
organize things for my friends dinners
whatever I'm sort of that guy and I'm
fine with that
on two conditions one just be
appreciative you don't have to buy me
anything you don't have to pay me back
nothing be appreciative and two
don't complain right right like I'm
doing all the work we wouldn't get
together if it wasn't for me right would
you say your writers if it weren't for
me
it's good for you if it weren't for you
if it weren't for me yeah so that you
know but I know it's sort of one of your
things and you're working on it and
you're you've been working on it your
whole life but you're kind of like
you're the guy who's like let's go and
explore and this but I probably I think
when it comes to like style and dress
you you seem like you're I have to look
I have to wear my collared shirt I look
more not that you don't look presentable
no you're laid back but he's the Style
guy he wins yes yeah you spend a lot of
money on clothes I don't actually but I
like to put myself together just so it
feels like he does professional yes
right and like we had one interview I
remember it was with the LA times during
Smallville and they were describing us
and they said miles was like very put
together and he goes and he's like this
one is laid back and rumbled and that's
what I was like yeah you know I should
work on that a little bit so yeah do you
picture with me like that kind of
rumbled you're not you're not rumbled no
no you're stylish you're you're stylish
I think I was a little more stylish
today but usually I'm sweatpants when
I'm interviewing yeah other than that
it's just it's kind of me but yeah you
have that stall Charisma yeah you get
away with a lot of [__] yeah
yeah now let me ask you this you've
known each other I'm gonna guess I'm
gonna go with
seven years almost yeah 30 years you've
been together yes now this was a long
time ago when you when you're on the
podcast last right I think we I don't
even we're in this room we were in this
room it was pre-covered it was pre-co
yeah but I remember us talking about you
know you you sold an orangutan film for
400 000 and uh you know the movie didn't
get made but kind of gave you a jump
start into you and I'll give you inertia
right to sort of like you know and um
but if you look back do you look at each
other and think that's the miles I knew
at USC that's the owl it's it's
relatively it's the same guy for the
most part do you really understand yeah
we have I think obviously people people
evolve and we've yeah definitely but
yeah but it's but it's like but still
and I think that's the thing about you
should grow older yeah basically the
same person just trapped in somebody
else's body right it's just like that
strange like really I'm getting old I
don't feel it yeah I think you feel that
your experience as you grow older is
actually you become more alive
and you do definitely I think get
malware in some ways yeah when we talk
about this you know even doing this show
versus Smallville which was you know 22
years ago where like you know the
30-something version of us would have
been Furious but the 50-something
version of us is like well yeah we'd
have been raging Maniacs yes
sorry 20 years yeah it would have been
like it's a different with different
people haven't gone through the
Smallville experience yeah having a hit
show yeah not this experience is coming
Wednesday so it's a very different then
I say we're very very different people
having had that experience yeah the ups
and downs and the sort of roller coaster
of anyone's career you've got to learn
from that have the roles reversed in a
sense that I remember on Smallville it
wasn't I'm I'm not going to use the word
feared because you weren't like this
Mega maniacol mean you know mean the
people you're always very kind and sweet
but what I mean is uh it felt like you
know Al was the one that sort of kind of
talked to and he was kind of calm and
you were but like if anybody's gonna
lose their [__] and say no that's not
working it felt like it was Miles who's
like I won't stand for that and maybe
you were that too but you sort of needed
to be the balance do you think that
those roles have sort of um you know are
they the same in a sense or now have
they shifted a little is Al a little
tougher well or are you both kind of
relaxed a little more now
well I think I think interestingly the
roles we because you know I mean the job
of showrunner which was not a term that
was even around 22 years ago but but
it's it's actually a lot of jobs oh yeah
it's good to have two people and the
division of those jobs is kind of really
what it was I mean we sort of figured
out like I I'll handle like
Studio Executives and I can't deal with
animals and like and I'll I'll you know
but then but then the thing is it's like
I'll be honest I I I'm not really a set
person like you know miles loves being
on set he directed
I love I love the I love sets I love the
camaraderie of the crew I love the crew
just generally in terms of that what
they do and watching them work and
um I think that's a really interesting I
love being there the weird stuff that
Crews get to do right being stay up all
night and seeing the door and watching
you know incredible you know license
effects Into the Woods at night I just
like the the magic of movies that comes
with me on a set
um which feels like a very special thing
to be in this business to see I'm going
to like weird locations that no one else
can get access to I think that's the
magic of it for me and seen then making
sure that the scenes are as I imagining
them in our heads so yeah like the
guardian of like our vision onset
um and I'd rather just be in a room
writing yeah yeah but you know funny is
I picture like look if you if you look
at both you know I would want without if
I didn't know you I'd be like I want the
English guy talking to uh Australian
slash English guy talking to the
executive because he just sounds you
know it's like well it just sounds like
it's smart you know but you don't like
it you don't feel comfortable well no I
I feel like I think I've got a lot
better you have it's just in terms of
being it's all about being defensive and
I think that's something oh so you're
worried about being defensive yeah I
think it's always about being defensive
in terms of like taking people's ideas
on which we always I think the thing
that we've done in our career and
has done well for us is that we're very
openly collaborative we really welcome
everyone's thoughts and ideas yeah I
agree from every element from any we'll
take a good idea from anybody literally
and it's and this and the the project
isn't the episode or movie isn't
finished until you literally deliver it
so the whole process from The Writer's
room from the set from the actors the
directors and then editorial yeah it's
all ongoing process it's constantly
evolving and that's something that we
sort of honed on Smallville and then
something that's continued and I think
we call it even better for us in terms
of like making sure that and we get all
the ideas and it's a continual
collaboration with every element of the
show now you said something about uh
sort of articulating or that Vision that
you both have and putting it on screen
so being on those sets and seeing the
forest lit up and all these things and
like that's that's what we want that's
what we want
um
I guess knowing each other this many
years you you assume like there's no
question I know Al will like this I know
this is what we both want is there ever
those moments where you're like what is
that you're like oh I love it and you're
like very rarely right I can't really I
can't really no way miles what are you
doing no no it's never had that no isn't
that crazy it's really insane we've
always been incredibly in sync yeah and
if we do surprise each other it's like
wow that's better than I imagined
um and all the all the issues are
otherwise solved in script stage you
never get to a point like oh this is
like what were you thinking it's like
it's always we've resolved any
conflicts just like differences of point
of view in terms of in the writing phase
yeah and that's just
it's always the anxiety of a writer is
like oh they're gonna [__] it up on Sam
is the director gonna [__] it up is the
exactly [__] it up are you sort of
waiting for that moment no I think it's
always the anxiety of a writer that that
the other element's gonna [__] up your
vision like that it's not going to be as
good as you hoped or as you as you and I
think what's amazing is when it actually
is better yeah and that's that's the joy
like oh it's exactly like you want it to
be so certainly on Wednesday it was like
wow this is better than we imagined or
it's exactly like we we
we could have thought and hoped yeah and
similar with Nutter on Smallville yeah
it's mobile pilot was like oh my God
this is everything we wanted it to be
and better yeah and that's what you want
it it keeps getting uh elevated by each
different person who comes into it
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look if you're
thinking of giving you therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside inside
of you is brought to you by Harrys why
didn't I know about Harry's why weren't
they around when I was doing Smallville
and they were shaving my head with these
cheap razors Ryan
seriously and there's you go to the
grocery store and there's all these
razors and I'm not going to name them
but
you think they're the best but they're
not I use Harry's Razors actually well
how do you feel about it I feel great
in a sea of options Ryan it can be hard
to find a high quality razor you can
depend on but look Harry's makes it easy
they consistently give you better razors
than in-store options at the best price
and they're refilled when you need them
and delivered straight to your door so
you can choose Harry's once and they'll
take care of the rest that's awesome
because you run out of a raise and then
you have to use a dull one and then you
got Nicks and stuff all over your face
and you look like freaking Linda Blair
from The Exorcist you don't want that uh
you know I love Harry's Razors they send
stuff to me and it just makes it easy I
just put them in my drawer they're
always there I'm never gonna run out and
now I know I'm getting the best razor
also it's better for your face yeah
because it's a better razor so you're
not again you're not nicking yourself
it's a smooth shave that's what you want
you want the best razor it's your face
you have it till you die oh my God be
nice to your face be nice to your face
look get a quality shade without the
hassle with a three dollar Harry's trial
setting the starter set is 13 value for
just three dollars at harrys.com inside
and it includes a five blade German
engineered razor weighted handle foaming
shave gel and a travel cover plus you
can schedule replacement blades delivery
whenever you need them with refills as
low as two dollars and you know Rosie
Harry's makes more great self-care
products than ever before like what like
shaving creams for before and after you
shave body washes hydrating lotions and
more wow guys who have tried it say
their eighth shave is as sharp as their
first
good blades yeah Harry's has the highest
customer satisfaction in the Shaving
industry and they're still offering a no
risk trial don't like your shave no
worries it's on them save the hassle set
up your delivery and get the best
quality shave with Harry's get a 13
starter set for just three dollars at
harrys.com inside that's harrys.com
inside for a three dollar starter set
was there um is there ever a moment I
know there's a moment there's moments
but like even with a great director like
Tim Burton who's this legendary Larger
than Life character that you know
there's that the movie star the old
school movie star that sort of
mysterious that doesn't really exist
anymore but Tim Burton it's still he
still has that mystery to him right you
know and that that
um that appeal and that
sophistication and
um he's a legend but are there times on
set where a big director like Tim Burton
or Tim Burton you're watching something
and it's in your thinking yep that's not
what I want [__] how do I tell Tim
Burton this how do I say Tim yeah this
is great but it's it's not what we're
looking for
it was it was an interesting because Tim
was actually he's actually been a
fantastic collaborator and he was
incredibly collaborative in the in the
prep part and certainly in the post and
then when he was shooting that's where
it was we had to figure out how to do I
remember the the first day on set
and it was his first day shooting and he
hadn't shot in a couple years either so
you know it's the first day of anything
he's kind of nervous and getting going
and we had some notes and we and then we
realized at the moment like this is not
this is not gonna work this way so we
went to him the next morning again this
is I think where maturity comes in and
he said look Tim we don't
yo here we go you're Tim Burton we you
know but we want to be deeper we want to
be respectful of your process and we
don't want to like so how do we do this
so how do we do this and he was and
we'll say that initially and he was very
he was very intrigued by the idea of
Gene TV yes and he was very intrigued
telling his story over a longer form so
he had never really done TV
I mean I think he'd done some episode
like back before he was Yeah Tim Burton
like in the in the yeah always been
intrigued by it he had never done a
streaming show or the idea of how do you
tell a story about eight hours well
Eight Episodes that was something that
he's that really intrigued him
um and he liked the when we first met
with him over Zoom or was he over his
face time call yeah it was he he liked
that we'd done TV before and he knew he
knew Smallville and so it was something
that
he really was like looking to us to help
navigate that new new world I mean he's
obviously doesn't need any help doing
anything but but he was deferring to you
in a way it was just he wanted to
collaborate like you know you're using
like good guys to take me on this
journey and we can do it together and
that's exactly how it was it was just
amazingly collaborative
um experience in every aspect and then
even in in post it was like you know
this is where we got nervous like a team
with Tim you think oh [__] what are we
gonna do and the way it works in TV is
you know Michael as you the director
does the cut and then the show Runners
get the cut and that's it so here we've
like we're not gonna cut Tim Burton like
how is that going to work right but
um
because he's always got Final Cut in his
movies so it's like who you know what he
knew that you guys get Final Cut well we
I we didn't it's not really fun but what
we said is if we have some notes like we
can we'll try anything you don't like to
we'll we'll take out and we went and did
a pass and he watched it and the great
thing about Tim is he just watches it if
nothing bumps him he's like yeah that's
great and he went and watched it he goes
yeah that's terrific and then when he
got to his next Cuts he's like okay you
do your cut because then he would get
ideas from it like he would see yeah and
then he also loved the idea like we had
the sequence in episode two which was
the canoe race the PO cup which you know
there wasn't really enough time in the
schedule to shoot everything so but we
said we'll put this together and then
we'll storyboard the rest and then you
get to go shoot more which I think
weirdly it was a little like animation
for him where it's like oh you can go
back and get the things you don't
right because because of the continuous
production of television and then what
we would do is include the dance as well
he saw his own car the dancer oh
actually I want more stuff you guys I
want this and this and and he's he's wow
yeah but what we would do is in the
mornings we'd meet with him in his
trailer and we go through the scenes of
the day and he he'd just be like
highlight beats like let's you know talk
through anything and the other thing too
is because it's obviously it's a big
mystery he goes you you all have the
bigger story in your head so tell me
like this make sure we get this because
it's going to pay off in episode five or
something so he was he was actually he'd
cut lines he didn't like yeah to trims
it was a really like just yeah very
elegant simple way to start each day
yeah yeah so we're all on the same page
and then we wouldn't have to bother him
on set yeah then he would just go and
and you know it's funny because the
first you were talking earlier like you
look at things you're like is this gonna
you know when it was Tim but you watch
something so we were we just didn't
understand how some things were going to
cut together right and then when we saw
his first cut we were like holy [__]
well is this the economy it's shots it
has the opposite of a TV director who
just covers the [__] out of a scene Yeah
Tim shot with one camera
One camera so so like so that the studio
would call us and be like where's the
coverage we're like there is no coverage
yeah you have to make him she was more
than one cameras like we're gonna make
Tim we're not making Tim Burton do
anything and you want Tim Burton and
this that Tim Burton style and this is
what it looks like and this is how you
achieve it wow yeah and multi-can two
cameras or more that would have just the
look would have been different yeah
because it's a different lighting
exactly it's all set up for one shot
yeah and this is how it's gonna work but
the economy of his storytelling is
unbelievable what what what a lot of
directors would take multiple shots in
he could do in like one or two it's just
it's just in terms of the
their ass basically yeah the second
episode begins with a there's a
um
missing kid basically there's a sort of
like a dog's police dogs through the
woods which you know I think we'd
schedule like four or five hours for
this big thing and he did it in three
shots three shots and it actually you
know you have no idea you're looking at
three shots yeah when you look at the
things it looks like it's multiples and
it's just like okay so it's really fast
working with a master film yeah that's
confidence it's absolute confidence in
what's what you're doing and completes
completely like his storytelling is just
amazing you can really see the
insecurity with so many directors as
we've got to shoot so much stuff that I
know I'll get something out of this
exactly whereas I need this I need this
and I need this these tell the story
is he's a Storyteller whereas whereas
most certainly in in television which
fine is they're they're they're covering
it right they're covering a scene where
he'll he directs it like it's here's the
shot here's how it's staged here's the
perform and then he tells the story that
was that was definitely eye-opening for
us yeah yeah and the way he handles
himself in terms of like
you don't think a guy like that would be
at all malleable you know or uh sort of
you know you know this is the way it's
done this is how it is and there are a
lot of directors like that it'd be like
no I don't want these guys on set get in
the [__] away from me right I'm not you
know Egos and this and that and he's all
about hey how do I make these guys have
a lot of experience in TV I don't I'm a
Movie Maker I'm a filmmaker I do all
these you know I have to
listen because it's smart to listen to
people who know what they're what
they're doing and he just it sounds like
he just respected you and he wanted to
to get your vision across and and
amazing you know yeah no it was it was
it was really we didn't know what to
expect and it was really an amazing
experience for everybody yeah does he
ever loses [__]
I think everyone's I mean also it was a
very it was really challenging tough
tough yeah we were shooting in Romania
which is an incredible country that was
the weather it was tough we should know
over winter it was nine months and it
was really it got cold and
um it was covets we had the really it
sounds we're not complaining but the the
you have to double mask and you get
tested every day it's such a hindrance
like so it's just yourself it feels like
you're a little one step removed also
it's it's I mean maazai
you know shot you know New Zealand
Canada Ireland but we had we never
really shot in the country where English
is in the first language and then so you
put that on top of masks and it's
definitely had the war in Ukraine and
they would never they were never going
to invade but there's a certain level of
anxiety that the American caused had
with that yeah and also you realize how
close nuclear power plants are how many
Ukraine has and how and how close they
are to like if one if if Chernobyl went
you're like it's LA to Portland that's
how far away you are so it's it's a
little they're so efficient yeah yeah
um wow yeah it's amazing people don't
see a lot of times they they see the
glamor in it they watch Wednesday and
they go wow this is beautiful and great
storytelling and writing and everything
it's just the music and Jenna is amazing
and all this stuff and they don't see
how hard it is to get that to get one
hour of a show but they shouldn't that's
that's not the
I know but I sort of I sort of want them
too because you know when people come to
set and they want to see what you're
doing they're like oh my gosh you're
doing this scene again it's like
watching paint dry it's like the worst
thing ever is being on set yeah so it's
like I wish everybody would know like
they all think like I could act I could
do this wow that was yeah this doesn't
look that hard yeah easy job and look
we're all grateful and happy to be doing
it but at the same time it's not
glamorous it's not good you're usually
shooting
warehouses or somewhere you know where
nobody would want to be in the middle of
the night so I mean it's you know it's
well Rogers used to say everybody has
two businesses their business and show
business so that's just thought it is
still what's great about it it's always
different it is yeah every day is a
challenge yeah when you're making
something every day something else goes
wrong that you don't expect so how do
you assault so it's constantly like
problem solving and making things work
that shouldn't and then budget gets
caught and so okay how are we gonna make
this work it seems impossible but then
you have to find the creative solution
behind it but it's just to me it's
always a privilege to sit there on a set
and think this is actually you know we
sat down at the farmer's market and came
up came up with this idea and here we
are like okay take me back to the
pharmacy you're at the farmer's market
you get a sandwich or something you're
sitting down actually but huh you're a
donut what'd you get pulp Stone oats
yeah donut too yeah coffee hot chocolate
we got iced tea and Bob's Donuts yeah
I'm just painting the picture here for
folks yeah this is a place over on uh
Third Street yeah and uh it's a farmer's
market there's shops and little so
imagine these two guys old friends 27
years 30 years 30 years well at the time
28. yeah and they're sitting down for
donuts and who says you know what
gotta think of uh Wednesday Adams was an
interesting character
how did it start well it's it's it
started I mean it was honestly we were
we had been back from we 've basically
been away for four years from like 2014
to 2018 making the Shannara Chronicles
so we were in New Zealand and Ireland
and that was Hogs and that was literally
just different different sides of the
world making shows yeah and then going
to Toronto to do posts yeah it was like
there was it was a crazy setup which we
should never have done but
we our problem was always but we never
say no to anything so we had two well
this is also we were trying to get both
shows in one place and then we ended up
literally if you if you dug a hole
through the Earth from Auckland to
Dublin you'd hit it like we were that
far away it was like lady Hawk like if
miles we could talk to each other at
like 7 A.M and 7 P.M like that was it
was a it was literally a 12-hour time
difference so we we were we were back
you know we've done these two you know
big
fantasy post-apocalyptic shows both were
huge World building and then you know
it's it's always a thing though you're
you're basically back at the bottom of
the mountain trying to find your next
show
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh do those thoughts keep you
from showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72 hours sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
and we kind of wanted to do something
with young people and we were and comedy
and comedy is something that was that
we've
because into the Badlands is incredibly
brutal martial arts show it was really
Relentless and very difficult to shoot
in terms of it wasn't fun it wasn't fun
and the show visited the set yeah and
the show the show was that was fun yeah
the show was great yeah we're really
proud of the show I think it's a show
that was underappreciated but because it
was it was ahead of its time but
um we want to do something we wanted to
do something smaller and more like this
is our little show about a girl in
boarding school and also to be honest we
wanted to do a show for our daughters
yeah because you have two daughters each
right yes yeah yeah and we also kind of
part of it was like the like Smallville
which is like is there an iconic
character who's that there's a chapter
that hasn't been told and so we kind of
got to Wednesday Adams and then yeah you
have a uh sort of uh
propensity yeah yeah
I think we own that corner now
teenage years teenage years yeah yeah so
yeah it was so we were so we kind of
wanted to it's a little like getting
back to your roots little how do we
change it up how do we do something
that's in set present day even though
but who brought a building show do you
remember who brought it up it came well
it came out from Al because alibin had
been at MGM for with some friends and
they're working on the animated movie
um and Wednesday was the highest testing
character in the animated movie and we
thought oh that's a really interesting
so we're like oh if that what if that's
live and here's what's interesting is
they didn't know who had the live-action
TV rights so we basically came up with
the whole show on
specs and then went to Paramount and
then well we we had and then this is
also did the original live action movie
no so we thought oh who has it does
Paramount have it or because MGM was
doing the animated movies and it turned
out that mg GM had the rights but they
had a very contentious relationship with
the rights holder who's a guy named
Kevin mizraki who was
um Charles Adams's
um like landscape architect who
befriended him and his wife and when
they died they left him the estate and
he's built it into this and actually
incredible
you know franchise what because I don't
I don't think what we either of us
appreciated was that The Adams Family is
still incredibly popular around the
world well clearly right no no but no no
but but I don't think but we didn't I
don't think we sort of we're like anyone
appreciated The Adams Family but we're
like you know because there's a there
was a musical about 10 years ago with
Nathan Lane
um and I can't remember who played
Morticia it ran on Broadway for a year
to be honest not not a terribly good
show it has been the number one
produced High School show for the last
10 years licensed so when people go
what's my spring musical gonna be it's
The Adams Family so interestingly kids
know The Adams Family the animated movie
came out they made 200 million dollars
so it's one of those things people love
it so you're saying you sort of do the
research of you know demographically uh
genders who's watching is there do you
do that before you come up with ideas no
no this was something where it was like
oh here's a character
nobody knew who had the rights it's
clearly just sitting out there it's not
here's the other thing it wasn't owned
by a studio right there was a there was
a separate Adams foundation and so we
um with the help Steve Stark was the
president of MGM television at the time
he's now a producer on the show and
Andrew mittman who was his executive and
they so we went in and we had done this
thing we pitched it to them they loved
it was pretty it was like a 20 Page 20
Page detailed Bible of what the series
should be which is very simple the show
is yes it's with all the characters and
and the world and the mythology of
Nevermore and what the first season
would be in terms of laying out the
mystery stories it was and what was part
of it was and this is all on spec in
terms of what we it's good we always do
this anyway just so we know what the
show is before we go pitch it yeah so
it's something we do whenever we do a
show right so they were like great we
don't even know if we have the rights we
pitched it but first we pitched it to
the rights holder who who really loved
it because he you know saw he said there
was a which is true there's a
sophistication to the Charles Adams
cartoons which he didn't feel got
captured in a lot of these animated
things they felt more Kitty and he liked
this because it felt more true to the to
the tone of of his original work so he
was on board right and then MGM threw
various legal things because of the
animated films had was called the right
of of last negotiation so which
basically means if anybody else tried to
come in if MGM came in with like a
dollar more they could get the right so
MGM negotiated the rights and then we
went to we went out and pitched it
around town and had
one buyer which was Netflix so only one
buyer only one buyer wait wait how many
did you pitch we pitched five at least
and they all said no and yeah and so
Netflix so Netflix this was in this was
in late 2019 and then Steve said write
the pilot because you know they we had a
con at that point we had a deal so we
wrote The Pilot script and then MGM and
Netflix
couldn't agree on a deal on a license
fee for it so which is how much they're
going to spend per episode like how big
a budget you have for purpose though
they couldn't agree on that yeah and
then how much how much the the studio
was gonna get because it's they're not
Partnerships anymore the way it used to
be in broadcast television the the
outside studio is basically working for
a fee it's like a contractor working for
a fee who then gets hit with the
overages if there's a problem right it's
not a great setup it really is not a
great setup right but we so suddenly it
was could make a deal it was dead but
then Steve got MGM his bosses to finance
a writer's room
for 10 weeks for us to break out the
rest of the season which we thought was
crazy because we're like What streamer
is going to buy a show that they didn't
have a hand in developing yeah but we're
like if this keeps it alive we'll do it
so it was Miles myself and two other
writers that's expensive yeah no it was
not cheap and and it was and it became
the first Zoom room because we started
the week of lockdown which feels writing
a show about Wednesday Adams during a
global pandemic feels on brand so you
know
um yeah so we so we basically broke out
the rest of the season had had written
at that point four I four or five more
scripts and we knew okay if we're gonna
go out with this again as a bigger so
round two of pitching round two of
pitching we need a we need a big
director element and Tim was always at
the top of our list and everybody's like
Tim Burton's never done television and
you know I started in sales out of
college I said well if you don't ask the
answers no so we got it to
uh Tim's agent and then we thought okay
it's we may never hear from him usually
as you know it's active as you're an
actor like you send active scripts you
never hear back before it takes eight
weeks to get back and then they pause
yeah it's like oh he finally read it oh
yeah it's a pass it's like it's just
it's throwing things into the ethers
it's like just it's never it never
happens you never hear back never hear
about and then four days later we heard
back Tim read the script he loved it he
wants to get on a on a call with you to
talk about it and Mike Simpsons is his
agent who's a huge agent over at wme's
Quentin Tarantino and and we said oh
great well he set up a zoom or something
he goes no I'm going to send you Tim's
number and you can FaceTime him tomorrow
because he lives he lives in England so
we did and it was like a classic
wherewithy Tim has this this place in
near Oxford this beautiful like country
estate and the garden is filled with
these life-sized dinosaur like statues
so he's standing there in his dinosaur
Garden talking to us on his on his and
losing reception it was just like
surreal moving around we're like we
can't believe we're talking and he's
like I love the script he goes like are
you nervous yeah Tim Burton yeah so
you're just going like and we have a
number and I had never done a FaceTime
before so I was like up early practicing
it with my kids going like oh if I put
this I have to put two numbers in this
thing how do I do it zero one one four I
don't know what the hell this is right
right so we did it and he's like I I
love the script I felt like you were in
my head like it it all I would have
dated Wednesday Adams in high school and
we were like oh my God like it was
amazing we're like great you know
because we have this that goes so you
know we're like do you want to would you
like to direct the pilot because I want
to direct all of them he goes do you
have more and then so he he ended up
doing four of the eight so you would
have done more he would have done all of
them what are the odds it's zero I mean
everybody's passing you get a writer's
room when you don't even have funding
really except for yeah you know you
don't no one's bought it's like you're
doing all these things that sound like
this is not how it works it's a waste of
money it's not happening this is what
they always tell you yeah I pitched a
show and I loved it and I had the whole
thing and then the series but the Bible
and they're like no I'm like oh and my
age is like well write something else
that's right yeah that's usually thank
you yeah why do you keep going why do
you keep going yeah and so and so we got
Tim and then we went out again and this
time we sent the pilot script out and
the Bible and then we set up zooms with
us and Tim and everything
and we had one buyer Netflix same
Executives uh teddy bear wait a minute
yeah you got Tim Burton and you got five
episodes written and you've got this
home this is exactly the pilot is
they're all exactly the same as but we
we we made yeah those are the episodes
we made and and literally Netflix it was
uh teddy bear Sally and coral Wright who
who had bought it the first time who
loved it who loved the pitch bought it
again and then this was in August of
2020 and then you know how it just seems
to work now it took like seven months to
close the deal and the deal was closed I
remember it was inauguration day of 2021
and then we were you know then it was
immediately green lit we were Off to the
Races and you know and then you have the
problem of that's when the world was
starting to open again for Film
Production there was no place in the
world available to shoot and they were
trying to send us to Toronto and the
issue we were having was sound stages
because the Tim Burton look is
predicated on sets big sets that require
very big sound stages and I think the
sound stages they were trying to jam us
into were like like 19 foot sound stages
this is this is highest experience
and then and then we got look and then
so we
called our producer from into the
balance is there any space in Ireland is
there and the places we had shot in
Ireland Ireland was full but then the
places we had shot had turned into
basically covet testing centers or
because of brexit they become like UPS
centers because of just how goods were
being transferred I mean so that was off
the table we ended up we had and then
suddenly Romania was the one place it
was so fitting though no it's purple
it's always meant it was meant to be it
was yeah and so we better just shoot the
ones Adam showed in the home of Dracula
and we and we went and we were like okay
first we gotta how are we gonna like
what's Tampa like we gotta get a tip on
board and we called them and we said
here's the thing and we put up little
like a deck together and then we showed
it to him and then he literally pulls up
on this phone it's a picture of him and
Alice Cooper at Dracula's castle so he
was we were like okay they've gone there
on a bloody trips on just a trip like he
just went there for fun so we're like
okay this is good and then miles went on
a scout with Tim by the way this is the
first time he met him in person yeah
working for like nine months to go yeah
nine months together all over Zoom like
we we talked to give you a hug daily
overview of course yeah I didn't know if
he was a hugger or not sorry I hit the
mic
um and so and he and then there was we
went to Romania which again as miles had
turned out to be perfect because we had
this massive studio called Busta with
these incredible sound stages a huge
kind of empty Backlot field where we
built the entire town from scratch Woods
right is the opposite way to this which
is like The Yoga Factory in the middle
of town this is like the most where you
were just driving to every location just
like Warner Brothers but just imagine a
haunted Warner Brothers yeah with weeds
growing out of every corner of the city
it's still there yeah yeah yeah yeah you
got to keep it going oh yeah for next
season yes exactly right so it's but
then you gotta come check it out is it
awesome to see oh it's amazing I mean it
was a you know and they and you know a
production designer found these great
Craftsmen so all of those gargoyles and
statues and everything was all I mean
the local Romanian crew
I mean we really didn't bring in that
many outside you know when you like film
crazy like they shoot in the country and
then they bring in a ton of people local
but yeah but why still it's still
incredible and this is a classic
Hollywood stories we only ever had one
buyer it's like stranger things had they
had one buyer it's E.T Star Wars
anything that seems to and this was we
had no anticipation or expectation the
show would be as big as it was or is
so I love the fact that only one person
only one I can't name the other Studios
that passed we can guess every other
every other streamer just every other
student HBO everybody passed yeah do you
think they're probably those execs are
fired now
I don't know if those execs were still
there to begin with you know just given
all the the churn but because no one
knows
I don't blame them it's not like I know
but no no one knows but unfortunately
these most of the people that are at
Studios it's fear-based yes
um I don't want to get fired I have to
appease I have to agree I have to very s
it's very seldom that you find people
that are like I see this Vision I see
what you're gonna do
no let's do this and Netflix the guy was
his name Teddy Teddy be a Sally yeah and
he was absolutely gung-ho did you know
100 like 100 did you know right away in
the room like this guy's gonna buy it he
wants to buy it yeah yeah because he's
one a fan of genre and this is always
for us when when Tim came on board it's
like you got Tim button and you go
Wednesday items that is a marriage made
in heaven like in terms of the two
things come together like God how do you
you really have two worldwide Brands
yeah like how do they how do you make a
deal because like oh my God these guys
created small little creative in the
Badlands and create all these movies Tim
Burton oh my God they're gonna drain us
we're not gonna have a budget We're not
gonna have any money that's part of the
fear isn't it yeah yeah because that's
probably it's like we're gonna have to
pay so much money in overhead right yeah
that it's like is it worth it right how
are we gonna you know right and uh but I
will say I mean compared to well that
said the budget wasn't High we had
compared to Summer shows it was actually
very yeah reason
budget for the time was 5.5 million that
was huge and that was um which is
probably like 10 million
um it's not more I think it's probably
more because when we did the the Aquaman
pilot a couple years later we were at
7.5 so man you can't tell me about that
what about the budget for this one you
can't I can't really say I can't no and
it's also it's difficult it's you're
doing all of them over it's included in
the eight yeah that's the other thing
too is they're you know back in the day
you had really episodic budgets right
now it's only one now it's kind of one
and you can't you know amortize things
the way you did before you know because
it's easier to take we're gonna build
these big sets but spread over 22
Episodes that's pretty reasonable 80
this is so some of it frankly the
accounting is kind of different the
economics yeah did Danny Elfman do the
music yes he did
guess what you see it on screen and you
hear it on the soundtrack yeah what you
pay for yeah let me say this uh how many
um Wednesday items did you audition for
again with those roles the way we did
with Smallville is you're casting a
super wide net but then you find the one
and this case was Jenna and she was the
one who was working
to be honest you can I'm Not Gonna Hurt
movie who was harder to cast Lex Luthor
or Wednesday Adams Lex Luthor Lex Luthor
was harder to cast it was yeah yeah
interesting yeah yeah so it was just a
no no it was it was it was a lot more
people it was a lot more here's what it
was it was a lot more people a lot more
interpretations but and and what we were
looking for it's it's a you know it when
you see it kind of thing and I think it
in in casting casting uh Wednesday is a
little like class in Clark Kent like
once we saw Tom and you just even if it
wasn't like a Perfect audition you're
like that's the guy yeah and also I
think Wednesday is even more iconic in
terms of you need someone who can
deliver the deadpan but have some soul
to that some there's something
underneath that so it's not just a cold
like something it has to be a innate
like a the person who delivers there's a
weird kind of almost like a a underlying
sweetness yeah and I don't know how she
does it yeah well you just you just are
that that's innate it's innate it's the
way it's the way Tom was with small like
there's a certain innateness that you
that you either and to be honest you you
had a dyslexia Luther we kept saying but
that like there my thing is like 50
different versions of Lex Luthor right
yeah different different flavors of Lex
Luthor yeah we were looking for a new
flavor that hadn't been seen before
which you had which you had but we
couldn't have described it before we saw
you we knew we wanted someone who had
the interesting yeah like we always talk
about the Michael Keaton yeah Michael
Keaton yeah bringing the comedic element
to it which was like you want someone
who has that comedic shops and the sort
of this is not an insult but the
neediness of a comedian like they need
the and that's what Lex says he needs
he's looking for love I guess yeah all
comedians they say have the sadness yeah
dysfunctions they're on the right guy
yes right and there's a Darkness down
there that yeah let's see but again
you just have to have that you can't act
that thank you so Mom yeah right no but
it's not that thing that that you just I
I know what you're saying there's
there's the tragedy of uh the first time
we're actually liking someone and we
know where he's going right and you're
like you don't want him to go there yeah
and it's sad it's like the Luke it's
like um Darth Vader it's like Anakin
Skywalker right yeah so it's like the
same tragic story where we don't want to
you know yeah so you want to save him
and he's unsavable yeah I mean the
casting for other characters who is the
second hardest character to cast
Morticia no we had I mean I think that
was pretty easy here's the great thing
Michael when you have Tim Burton you
kind of get your first choice for people
so he we and and it was you know more
and and what Tim wanted to do which
which we agreed was he wanted the
mortician Gomez to look like they did in
the Charles Adams in the comics so like
that so that makes sense for Louis
Guzman who looks more like that right he
looks more like that and then he also
though might as well said it's you also
want to understand why Wednesday because
this is a different kind of take which
is she wants to kind of get away from
her parents and so it's like if your
mother's an oscar-winning movie star you
you you go like oh I understand like
there's a how do you get how do you get
past that shadow or out of that the most
amazing actress was Gwendolyn Christie I
was just gonna say that and what I loved
about that is I wasn't used to seeing
her uh as so elegant and beautiful and
sexy and she and that was and it wasn't
like she was not playing Another Bad
carriage or another character who's
struggling inside it was it was
different than what I've seen her in no
it was and it was really cool cool yeah
it was just and that was Serendipity and
it wasn't
necessarily what we imagined but she's
perfect once we like we saw a picture
and it's like oh my God it was just it
became inevitable right once we sort of
like thought about and the size
differential as well between Jenna and
gwenzel in those scenes is just there's
a magic between those two two actresses
as well like there's a chemistry that
really works that was just yeah you
can't predict and it was just and she's
she's lovely I mean she's like I gotta
meet her oh I think she'll get you think
she'd come on the podcast
what was
I this is gonna I don't think this is a
weird question I wonder if the studio
um thought or asked or somebody had
their hand up and said what if we make
thing
a female hand
was that ever brought up it you know it
wasn't and I think it's just because we
were trying it's
that's a departure that I think it would
have been when you're already doing a re
interpretation of The Adams Family and
focusing on Wednesday it might have felt
like a bridge too far like it might have
felt forced yeah
right but we spent a lot of time
thinking about it yeah in terms of
making him a real character and giving
emotional sounds ridiculous emotional
complexity and but it shows and the way
he yeah yeah he does things you know
what sort of like
yeah the perplexity yeah the assorted
you can release you can really the
stabbing of the yeah no that's one of
the most emotional moments yeah and you
like if on paper you'd be like um I
don't know is that right well that was
not gonna work and that was we agreed
like uh how is it gonna work so it's one
of those which we like to do is like
take a risk in terms of like you have no
idea if it's gonna walk and it could be
the cheesiest there's a rubber hand uh
you know stab to the wall why should you
give a [__] but
but it's like yeah so that's one of the
things and we had this amazing crazy
Romanian magician what's his name his
name's Victor dorobonto but we did all
these editions for a thing as well so
all these people come in and it was the
three of us and Tim uh and they were all
performing and then Tim would be doing
his do you ever do that yeah yeah Tim
would be like Tim was really engaged in
the hand movements and he'd get on the
floor and and it was like giving line
readings to a hand like Tim would get
down it was hilarious did you uh
the guy what's his name again Victor
Victor did Victor ever just like
sometimes you caught him like stretching
his
hands a glove because it was it was
colds there was some sort of big like
like
warming glasses yeah look look like look
like a kitchen like a mitt like you wear
her to keep his hand nice and warm yeah
yeah I mean he could probably after this
series go to conventions inside
autographs he already is yeah I'm
surprised you haven't run into them
fantastic yeah everything's so detailed
which it makes sense it's Tim Burton
it's you guys it's got to be
detail-oriented
um is it true Jenna Ortega came up with
the dance or is that just folklore nope
that's her dance come on the whole dance
the whole show she just brought it to
stage one day she lit Michael I swear to
God so we so Google muck was
so Miles had the cramps on a playlist
because we were obviously trying to
think of what the song is it wasn't
going to be like a current pop song it
had to be something kind of classic but
yeah also was because it was coming out
yes and so we had like okay we haven't
decided what the song's gonna be yeah
and you need the song before we can do
choreography right so finally this I
just did a playlist of my own like on
Spotify and then we sat we sat with Tim
when I was like probably like 15 songs
15 yeah and there was one cramp song on
that that he liked and said oh I know
another cramp song and then he he played
gookenbach yeah and we were like oh
that's the and then and then he there
was a choreographer but you know he went
to he basically went to Jenna and was
like he's like I'm sure you'll come up
with something great really yeah and
that was literally it it and then
remember you know just sort of watching
them film it and then going in and
seeing just an assembly of it the next
day with the editor and it was like this
could be like the Pulp Fiction dance
like that's what it I mean Lady Gaga was
doing the day yeah yeah I mean it was it
was incredible it was just like the
perfect
you know but what was but what was you
know and then this whole like thing
Jenna did it did have covet after that
because we tested really rigorously
every day when I had the full PCR test
everyone was fully masked and then uh
because the piss house was so early if
anyone had covered they were taken
offset immediately if the test came back
in the afternoon they'll take it out
immediately but anyone could get
infected because there's so minimal the
testing they can they can find the most
minimal like and social that was the day
it happened and as soon as she was does
a positive she was taking off sets and
there was never any Jeopardy and she
didn't know she had covered when she was
doing it but the fact that she
just bought it there was no we had the
choreographer didn't use her and it was
all her yeah because I said the next day
I guess I said the choreographer didn't
or was sorry it's like that I saw the
dance like that wasn't the choreographer
right she's like no she's like I did
that I'm like okay it's incredible right
yeah it's an incredible dance the
choreographer was upset but they didn't
use her dance I told him she's not
responsible for that yeah we had like
Susan and banshees and
um yeah a bunch of stuff yeah but just
it was perfect yeah that's great I mean
it's just so I mean when you look at it
from filming from being there is it
always just shock you how or do you sort
of know like I know what this is gonna
be when this is put together how special
this is gonna be or is it really does it
really happen in the editing room do you
really find it there I I would say in
this case because with with Tim and
everything we once we saw the assemblies
like the editing you know some some
episodes were tougher than others you
know as they are but it was it was all
there like when we left we knew we knew
the show was good like we knew we were
like we're really proud we were really
happy with it it's like it fulfilled
what we wanted to do you know what was
Miles said what we saw in our head so
some of those way better and
and then we wanted to always be
satisfying it's always the thing for us
you know in this new form of
Storytelling that it feels propulsive
and it's never boring yeah so it's
interesting we're watching episodes of
Smallville because someone's like okay
it feels like it's very networky in
terms of the the repetition and like
some of the episodes like a Duds like
and it's just you don't ever go into it
into 22 Episodes thinking they're going
to be so they're going to be dogs you
have expectations of Eight Episodes they
better be good because they got it all
right no that's what we think they have
to be good they have to be you can't
just have a dud in the age no no they
have to all be good and that's always
next nor should you right if you're
making eight because we're I mean
Michael we made eight in the schedule
where we made 22 of Smallville
right right so 10 months yeah it was
about it was about yeah it was like yeah
10 months yeah and also writing before
that so it's a three and a half year
process to get to the 10 months yeah so
the whole thing is just
they have to be great yeah unbelievable
so they're like we call them they're
like fabijay eggs they have to be great
yeah right and that's what we always
like set out to do yeah so they can't be
any any Duds yeah and it's just it's a
lot of pressure no it is because they're
I mean there's always pressure yeah yes
always pressure but then it's just sure
but yeah and also it's just I mean
it's just it's again with it's chapters
of a book versus short stories in the
world which is what Smallville was that
had mythology episodes that could tie a
season together and but but it was just
it's a it's a different order right is
what is really what I mean are there
some characters or or were there any
actors or characters that you you didn't
think really worked as well as you
thought and probably not going to come
back because maybe the characters just
didn't work you know what was
interesting with this one was and this
is mostly because of for for Budget
reasons and schedule and all these
things is we're always cutting so what
you know Wednesdays and 98 of the show
so I think at least with season two
it'll give us the ability now that
you've met some of these characters to
give them their own stories
I don't think anybody I mean other than
you know Wednesday and Weems because she
was in a bunch of the scenes and then
maybe eating a little bit yeah I would
say Wednesday Enid Wings got the most
like they're the characters the end
thing were the were the ones that people
because they had the most scenes because
they were in the most scenes with
Wednesday so I think I think it was a it
was very
interesting now to be like oh now we can
now that you've people are on the on the
ride they like the world they like the
characters now you can explore them a
little yeah yeah and we you know
obviously it's great to get a second
season so you can expand the world yeah
and we're always very hard on ourselves
and making sure that the show is as
propulsive and enjoyable and doesn't
would never complacent about the
storytelling yeah
something that people will enjoy and
find the light in do you find that now
that it's this Blockbuster I mean
probably the biggest show Netflix has
ever had right certainly one of them
yeah top three
with stranger things stranger things and
Squid games
wow good company yeah yes
um
we were like we're aiming for like
Umbrella Academy or like that would have
been so we love that show
but never expected it's insane yeah do
you feel like Netflix
obviously so supportive bought the show
from the first time around they they
said yes they were the only ones again
the second time around
do you feel like they're letting you do
your thing
for the most part they let us do our
thing the first season I mean they don't
really they've been great I mean they're
involved and they give and I said we
want we want their notes and their
feedback yeah and you know and they but
they were they were always behind it not
too invasive no no no and it's it's
again it's like we we welcome
collaboration that helps and makes it
better so it's always like being open to
ideas and open to like outside eyes as
well like you need fresh eyes sometimes
you're in you know you're in the hole
it's like okay guys you've lost the
track on this one so but but it's and
they were incredibly supportive and had
to continue to be supportive and yeah
you know we were very lucky that that we
had an amazing marketing campaign and
not all shows get a marketing game yeah
I know it was and it was one of the few
Ali Feinstein Who's the who did this
campaign for them she's a Netflix it's
one of the few times where you feel like
the campaign actually captured the tone
of the show like The Campaign was funny
how many times have you watched
something where you're like going that
that wasn't at all
or a trailer is misleading yeah you see
is what you get yeah like this is the
world we're going into yeah yeah you're
right and we're invited you know very
early end up riding a lot of the copying
stuff and then in the lines but but
still that's great yeah I would rather
be invited it in and help and actually
make it sure that it does feel like the
show because it the same voices are
writing the ads as they are running the
show so if you feel that and that was an
amazing experience yeah how soon after
did they say get back in the [__]
writing room let's go it was like it was
like a couple weeks when the couple of
episodes aired well as you know they
dropped everything so oh yeah it was
like a couple we had like the first like
because the data comes in immediately so
they know what's but they know
everything which is the amazing thing
they know when people stop watching when
they stop watching if they watch the
whole thing if they watch it again yeah
so
on this on the first Monday after the
after the drop we got we had an amazing
call with them saying Hell you know
they're like this thing's like of course
you know they they call and say you know
whatever that ad they put out like you
know how many 100 million minutes or
something and they're looking at just
like isn't this exciting and it's like
yeah but it's like telling me we won a
gazillion dollars like I don't know what
that but then when they put it in
context of where that falls with their
other shows I mean again they're an
incredible company when you see
I mean Wednesday was like the perfect
storm it was like they knew how to
Market it they were behind it 100 and
when you see the power of a streaming
service like Netflix it's like when when
they're behind something and it's just
like and when it when something's on
that show and then on that streaming
service works yeah and just it's like a
is this like a viral infection it just
takes off the word of mouth and it's a
global phenomenon overnight overnight
like you you think you guys like we were
again Smallville was an immediate hit
when it premiered on the WB but then you
had a season and then you had a summer
of reruns and then it sort of was in a
year later it was International and the
second season was bigger than the first
season of Smallville but what was what
was what was articulated because we're
much more relaxed about this right
problem with Smallville is you're in the
room still writing a real episode like
six when when that when the show
premiered and then you've got it's just
like the pressure to continue on a hit
show on network is so much greater
because you're actually in the you're
still making you're still in the Sausage
Factory and they're like they love it
keep making sausages they're still
battling yeah
and the train is going off the tracks as
you know like on the on the oh my God
just like holy crap season it's just
like a nightmare
um
how many scripts are done would you say
solid the witch for season two oh we
just we just saw back in there by this
room we just started yeah yeah we have
your breaking stories we're breaking
back before you came here today you were
breaking stories would you say you got a
good start for the first second season
yeah yeah I mean we've we're happy so
far pitch the we pitched him and pitched
Jenna and I think they're all like yeah
everybody's everybody's excited we're
we're you know Jenna has just blown up
it's incredible so much that I said can
you get Jenna because I don't think
Jenna's not gonna illegal but that's and
it must and that's one thing like you
know because for us she has her whole
team and everything no no but it's but
it's also it's just like I can't like I
was saying with you guys it's television
was always you were overnight kind of
with something worked it was like next
day people were recognizing you but to
be suddenly blasted out on on Netflix
and you're just around the world at the
same time is amazing I I don't and that
was just I mean she went I think she got
30 million followers when Wednesday
aired or something she's not at six and
she went to like 40. yeah yeah and some
people like went from you know we got
one kid who's like who's 13 on the show
who went from like 3 000 to 400 000.
yeah you know what's funny is I
I I love Jen Ortega Jenna Ortega is
great she's not just great on Wednesday
but I remember seeing her in you yeah I
remember seeing her in the next movie X
yes I'm like yeah I'm like she's great
yeah she's freaking great she could turn
it on and I'm like she's a movie star
because people will ask me they're like
I mean she's good right no this girl is
gonna be she's a movie star
she's got so much talent I you know she
seems like she's great to work with yeah
yeah she it's it's actually some of the
like with Wednesday she like it's like
super it's it's a little Supernatural in
a way and but yeah she's she's great and
this was just the perfect role that just
kind of it took a year that she was I
mean because screen you know screen
opened a 36 million dollars last January
and then she had she had X and all these
things it was like it was it was almost
like the her year just started and then
Wednesday at the end of it it just put
her into the stratosphere Christina
Ricci just briefly
um I hear it was hard to get her well
she was hard because she was pregnant oh
so we had to work out okay that's
different yeah that's different so we
had to scheduling we worked out the
schedules we should come and shoot all
the episodes at the end so she could do
be it Eight Episodes and do it in like
three weeks yeah so because she had
yellow jackets as well yeah Yellow
Jackets I saw I didn't finish it yet but
I saw most of the first season it was
pretty intense yeah oh yeah it's pretty
cool it's it's cool people and she's
she's fantastic to work with and that
was because she went with Tim on Sleepy
Hollow so it was just it was just like
we would really want to make it in The
Adams Family yeah obviously as we know
yeah so it was just like and to have the
two Wednesdays together felt like iconic
for this first season so it was just
like I'm gonna actually all worked this
was a show where a lot of things almost
didn't work and then they did yeah we
got the perfect cost
Fred Armisen oh my God fantastic
incredible so I hear he's just great
he's just he's great to work with great
to work with I would I think he could
improvise like any nobody's business
right you know he can but he but he but
he didn't so and did Tim ever ask him to
no because Tim didn't direct that yes
guess who directed that block Marshall
James Marshall yeah no and Fred was
honestly he wanted the role and he moved
his schedule around to do it and it was
always like a weird thing because then
we had a covet shutdown oh my gosh is
his window gonna get and he showed up
and shaved his head you see we only do
we only do people apply at the shape of
their heads and he just he was I hear
he's a great you know Judd Apatow was in
the podcast and he talks about how just
that guy can make him laugh like no one
else I'd sit in the trailer with him
just because I liked Fred I'm sure he
was like why is this producer always
coming to the trailer to hang out with
me in the morning but um you know be
like hey you want to talk about this and
then we talk about
um documentary now or we yeah it was
just sick of his music like um you know
huge he was he was great but also the
the transformation from Fred into Uncle
Fester was just like yeah it's like as
soon as he walked on set with the makeup
and the hat and the big like Monk's
cloak was like what the hell is this he
said because he he'd met Colleen in L.A
the costume designer to to try on in in
Fred goes I was like nervous because I
didn't know how I was gonna play like he
was just trying to figure it out for
himself and then he goes I put on that
costume
suddenly and he goes like weirdly he
goes I just had it you know I just
suddenly it just like it's all correct
yeah all right this is called [__]
talking with Alan miles these are my top
tier patrons they give back to the show
I love them go to patreon.com inside of
you to help uh rapid fire yeah oh gosh
Leanne what inspired you to do the show
Wednesday which you already talked about
what has been been your favorite part
about this project so far I mean he
pretty much said that but um favorite
part about this project I think welcome
to Timber yeah working with Tim Burton
forward with Tim Burton yeah my see what
future projects are you working on that
you're able to tell us about
we have a top secret project we can't
talk about but um is it a show no it's a
movie yeah which is a damn cool movie if
it happens yes is it action is it
Thriller is it drama comedy I'd say it's
like horror comedy would you call it
yeah probably that's it if it's a horror
comedy I better get involved look look
around you I know I know I know
love horror yeah not really I want to
play I think I'd be great as the next
like sort of like a Nicholson character
in The Shining yeah you could like lose
my freaking mind
like slowly you know my thing with you
is
you're you're very good and you don't
work enough so that's my that's my well
you know what unfortunately it's I mean
I hate to say it but it you know I mean
in a good way yeah but it's by choice
yeah yeah oh I know I know I just I feel
it's just something you're like the
Stanley Kubrick of of actors well it's
just that I think you know
I think for me it was sort of taking a
break a little break to sort of reassess
things and kind of like you know work on
me but also it's like I feel like I want
to do things that really excite me and
very seldom do you find things that not
only excite you because it's it's not
about the money right anymore it's like
you know I'm not like I don't have you
money but I didn't create Wednesday but
I'm saying that yeah I feel pretty happy
and content all these things and I just
want to do something that I'm like oh my
gosh I want to work with that guy sure
or I want to be so I'm open to things
I'm just like I haven't been
very receptive to a lot of the things
that have come at me right yeah
and how many times do I have emailed you
going yeah they offered me this and
you're like don't [__] take it don't
say anything yeah I won't but yeah but
that's by the way I I have said that too
yeah I mean our problem is always say no
but it's just like some of the stuff you
get it's like oh my god really this is
the month to do yeah that's a luxury
though we're blessed that we don't have
to do something I mean I agree wait
you've brilliantly you you oh and you
always did had so many you know music
and now I mean you got into the
podcasting business early and you're
great and you're great at it it's the
guests that you know you guys give all
the informatives yeah but there's still
a point but you're I think I when you
first season when I first heard you
forgot I was like you're a natural at
this so you know what's funny is I was
so I told tell Ryan I was like I used to
be so nervous about it and like you know
I get like you know it was anxiety about
it sure I want people and now I uh for
the most part like I'm just kind of like
hanging out like I'm like I'm not
worried too much like where is it going
right everyone so I kind of just listen
and and then all right yeah you know
it's kind of it's fun yeah you guys make
it easy uh Santiago what are your
feelings for Smallville 20 years later
again love it very grateful
it's incredible that it's still
the people still watch it and talk about
it and still meant so much to people I
heard
um annetto tool on talk bill this week
and um saying you know people come up
and say it's the show we watched as a
family which is and then we've done that
with Wednesday yeah that's really and
that's significant in terms of yeah the
the they call it co-viewing the Netflix
experience in terms of if people watch
something together it's called code
viewing and the code viewing on
Wednesday was through the roof yeah
family's watching something together
which was which was so important and
even and today it's even more relevant
because people don't watch anything
together everyone's watching the
individual phones or devices and to have
something that brings people together
the way Smallville did yeah and that's
always the most meaningful thing to ask
in terms of the fathers brothers and
daughters watching the show together and
I think we talked about last time the
idea that the troops watching the show
in uh Afghanistan in Iraq so profound
yeah I I am so always moved by that and
the letter that we believed and it's
just it's so to have a show that has an
impact in a positive way and both shows
are so life-affirming that it's it's
great to put that out into the world
yeah you know
um because Tom and I are obviously doing
the um the podcast talk Ville and Ryan
right here and and apparently me and
while I call yeah well I call Al for now
randomly and I go no I go I go you know
what I want to call Miles Gilly he's
he's out of the country right now I
don't know and I was like thinking you
know if you gave me your number I would
call you oh well you got to call me next
time yeah you know what it'll be like I
don't remember
it doesn't matter though I'll go miles
I'll randomly call you and if you happen
to answer yes I'll say Ryan and I put
you right here I'll say miles do you
remember we're doing this episode below
do you remember this no I don't remember
that but did you remember that sucked I
love you sound like Johnny Rotten
um you know the one thing that I think
the guys kind of laugh at me they saw
off um you know some people say you're
[__] on the show and I obviously
loved Smallville yeah but like to to
listen to watch episodes and re-watch
them and like we talked about 22
Episodes a year as you said they're done
so I'm very honest in my rating system
but like I'm like guys I I have two like
I just gave insurgents like a rose and a
half yeah
there's a lot of episodes where I'm like
you know and I think that you know I
feel bad sometimes you watch a couple in
a row and you're like and then you've
watched one that's so good and then you
watch you know and then story arcs and
things so there's so many there's so
many greatness to it but I'm also honest
about you know watching this and it's
also 20 years old too yeah of course oh
my God yeah but it's you know it's like
you know sometimes I'm like
you know it's hard it's hard the time
really loves nothing but you listen to
it I listen to it but and I do it's
funny because do you get mad at me no I
don't think
what I think is funny is when you're
doing the synopsis and there's some
times where I'm just like why don't we
do that yeah you know it's always like
things you you'd rewrite yourself you
know but I do think it's it's just
always hard under the it's The Crucible
of time yes on the Netflix on those
network shows yeah oh of course but I
mean we're critical at the time like
yeah I mean we're just like and
sometimes we just like okay that like
the the we haven't got to it yet though
the the baby blowing up exploding baby
oh my God what was that I think I think
it's like I think it's in like season
five or something it is like this is
this diabolical episode yeah and then
there was like and what you guys did
this was Redux which was the one
by the way that episode was shot after
the finale and when Beeman had fired the
crew yeah our finest out it was then
buried in season two yeah because it
made no sense it's buried there you
expect that because because they wanted
the license fee and because because it
was doing like it was deliberately put
on like the State of the Union day
because it was gonna be everyone used to
be low low ratings that day right yeah
so it was purposely yeah it was all
barrier it was literally like we have
this one let's just bury it on a Tuesday
where we're up against something big
yeah what was the one Ryan that we just
did that I didn't like I didn't hate it
but I I gave it enough turn the werewolf
one no uh yeah I didn't love that one
but it was more I gave it a heater it
wasn't bad or good it was the one where
two Tina Greer comes back and face
morphs into each person and there were
some moments the the greatest moment of
that episode was at the end when Lon is
crying about Whitney being dead that was
awesome I'm like that's the [__] joke
yeah that's the show well somebody just
build the show so that's one great
moment yeah we always talk about if a
show has three great scenes it's okay
you get to get through with it
um now but there are much more forgiving
like Ryan goes I I liked it yeah
that's why I feel like an [__] well I
feel like I'm the most critical of
Wednesday as well and the problems I
have with the show no one else seems to
have it's just like and I what were your
problems
I have all these problems with it and no
one's like that's fine it's like really
no or people just don't it is okay they
don't care or they're not and I remember
Peter Roth used to say because you have
an episode where he like didn't work and
he goes if people love the characters
and love the show they'll forgive an
episode or they don't care like he's
said because I said before it's comfort
food but also an avid viewer that was
watching One in four episodes so then
back then so so it was you know and and
you're right you have a couple and then
you have one still that's it it's still
heartbreaking because you want all of
them to be amazing of course and you sit
there in the writer's room and on set
and you believe it's going to be amazing
you have to and so is that the delusion
that you have that everything's you're
doing is going to be amazing do you know
by the way you have to bring us on for
Rosetta yeah I said yeah yeah you're in
yeah of course uh do you know there's
another reason why I I left after the
seventh season
because I signed on for the seventh
season yeah and I did that because
people don't understand that I actually
signed on for another year yeah
but part part of that reason was two
other people left after season seven yes
yeah yeah it was you guys yeah yeah and
you I knew that was happening yeah and
yeah I just felt like you know this is
kind of the end this is the time how
many more stories what are you doing
160. I know and that's for us it was
like we've done it so it's like yeah you
did it for the wrong reasons then you're
not doing it out of creative fulfillment
yeah and I wrote respect for everyone
who went on and did it and and I'm not
dissing them although shell I haven't
watched it but for us as creative people
it's like there's a certain point you
run out of juice that you're like in
terms of doing one thing you know and we
went on and wanted to do other things
yeah this was the end of the road for us
yeah yeah we have no more stories really
to tell or that we were in and not if
not and we understood again and we're
glad that you know the network and the
studio wanted to keep making the show
and frankly we trained people who would
like they were chomping at the bit to
get into the driver's seat and let them
right it's a thing is television is a
team sport if you're on a long-running
show at a certain point it's you step
aside and let people that have new ideas
or yeah energy and enthusiasm come in
and keep take it's like a [__] mirror
take the Baton and keep going so yeah
which is great it's almost like uh
sometimes you edit something and you're
just like yeah I just I just don't know
what else to do with this so you have to
give some young punk who's like you know
got the MTV mentality and he'll go and
he'll do something oh okay that's what I
need to say okay great do that that's
not what I do but yeah and those shows
it's just it and again it's something
that nobody deals with anymore because
how many shows are 10 years but you do
need that refresh to keep it interesting
and so it again we have no regrets love
the show like we did as long as we did
and we're certainly do not regret
leaving when we did and then don't
regret leaving when we did yeah I bit
one of my cuticles yeah
nasty yeah yeah I don't know why just it
was like a little thing hanging you know
you just kind of bite that off I think
it's all right though I think it's a
perfect time to end the episode
this is this is awesome you know it's
funny because I told Ryan before I Ryan
I was like
I had them on I I know these guys I you
know what am I gonna talk and they just
it just is easy with you guys and it's
so informative I think people are gonna
really love hearing this process hearing
about Tim Burton how how hard you worked
and how you just took this and kept
pushing when everybody said no and the
writer in writer's room and then getting
on the phone with Tim Burton and him
like getting it to Tim Burton just this
whole stuff and just these these moments
and like uh and to get you know it's
lightning in a bottle you know you get
it once if you're lucky and you did it
again
yeah and so yeah which is which is
fantastic I mean this is the thing it's
beautiful it's awesome it's the great
thing about Joe business it can always
surprise you yeah and yes and never
count people out no and it's just and I
think it's mostly now that you've we've
been through it you're just grateful
yeah you're just grateful anything that
would that's really that's the thing we
feel the most yeah just gratitude in
terms of yeah that it's that it's
completely unpredictable and all you can
do is put try and do your best work and
yeah and if it hits and react people
respond that's just such a incredible
blessing and surprise and we've had so
many people reach out from sort of All
Phases of our career to say how much
they enjoyed so that's also great that
actually has been incredible that's been
incredible like people we haven't heard
but they just it's awesome yeah it's
been great so well I love you guys I
love your success I'm happy for you I
hope we work together again absolutely
excellent thanks guys
foreign
ful for uh everyone's like you're
everyone in the room was like
responsible for everyone's career you
know what I mean yeah like they give you
yours and you sort of help them with
theirs yeah in a way yeah yeah it is
it's cool and you know let this be known
I mean they are in my opinion they're
Geniuses they're you know they come up
with these ideas and they execute them
and they know how to execute them and
the writing I mean the uh through line
that's all them this is what creators do
these guys have a vision
they write what they want to be seen and
tell the story they want to tell
let there be no discrepancy
I'm just gonna say that
uh thanks for listening um I'm gonna
give a shout out to all my top tier
patrons these are the folks that really
um on top of listening they they give
back to the show patreon.com inside of
you thank you become a patron today you
get shout outs you get boxes sent to you
my appeal will figure out the box that
got lost probably my fault but because I
pack them and uh all that stuff
um thank you for joining Paige we also
have uh YouTube lives with the patrons
we have sometimes you uh zooms with the
top tier patrons there's a lot of stuff
so get on there I'll write you a message
appreciate patreon.com inside of you
here we go top tiers
let's do it
I'm gonna put my other glasses on
I wish we would yeah because otherwise
this could be a really
unnerving oh and now I can't see you
crooked it's funny because when I have
to wear these I never wear these anymore
with the guests because they're blurred
far away gets blurry I'm blurry right
now you're not like the blur Witch
Project but you're like Witch Project
I'm like the band blur yeah you are um
all right when I feel heavy metal woohoo
all right all right Nancy D Leah s
little Lisa you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico
P Robert
Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D Jennifer
and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B Mikey
Eldon Supremo Good Old Dan how are you
Dan lovely
I love Dan
99 more San Diego am where's my statue
he made me a Lex Luthor like statue
wow yeah it's a different one it's like
uh like out of metal
like out of like cheese no no no no well
it's really cool we'll see Chad W Leanne
P Janine R Maya R Matty yes Belinda and
Dave hey Sheila G Reggie braggy and
Rachel
Tom and Liliana a Talia M Betsy D I
don't know what I was doing chat L Angel
amren and see Cory k e core K to have
next and Michelle okay hey hey Jeremy C
Brandy D Joey M Eugene n Leah Corey
Heather L Jake
uh think of the actor G no Jake he has a
crazy dad
oh uh B yep Jake B Megan T Angela F Mel
s Orlando C Caroline R Christine s Eric
H Shane R Andrew M Tim L Karina and
Amanda R Jen B Kevin e Stephanie K jorel
jam and J Leanne
Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone H Stone
Henge remember Miss s Brian L kdb Aaron
R Kendall L house J Meredith I Charlene
C Cara C Mary R Sheena L Jessica B Kyle
F Marisol P Estevan g k Lee J Megan K
Mickey L and Brian a couldn't do it
without you guys I thank you again and
again
um from the Hollywood Hills in Hollywood
California I am Michael Rosenbaum Brad
Tales everybody
a little way have you done that probably
a hundred times uh probably probably be
good yourselves uh we'll see you next
time thanks for making this podcast your
choice to listen to
foreign